when young people are told to stay at
home it's much harder to check
up on just how they're doing schools are
shut to most children
exams cancelled now new research by the
social mobility foundation has found
that half of disadvantaged children fear
they won't get the grades they deserve
a decade of progress closing the gap
with their more privileged peers
is now at risk my name's taylor i'm 17
and i'm
i'm living in wigan greater manchester
my name is misha i
live in leicester and i'm 18 years old
my name is mirza big
i'm 18 years old currently and i live in
manchester
i come from quite a disadvantaged
background my mother is
currently unemployed so none of my
immediate family
members have actually gone to university
i'm looking to do physics at
uh possibly manchester or cambridge your
mom must be really proud
yeah we always have uh sort of phone
calls and
conversations every her telling day
how bad she is of me and um yeah i think
that is my aspiration in life
you know to make my family proud um
because
they have they haven't come from the
most advantaged backgrounds
amisha is from a low-income family in
leicester her dad
is a forklift driver and the main
provider for the household
she's always dreamed of going to
university with the
korean situation with universities in
kobe 19 i'm
a bit concerned about going to
university because i just
given my background i can't i don't
really think it's
affordable to be paying 9 000 pounds a
year for tuition fees
and thousands of pounds in accommodation
for online lessons
it's quite concerning for me because i
i've always wanted to go to university
i've had it in my head
that my plan is to go to university i
want to study economics are you
concerned that um
because of lockdown because schools have
closed that
you know some people are getting access
to better education than others but
there's an unfairness there
private school students are
automatically just advantaged
and if they are if they're able to
afford to
pay for private education they must be
able to afford technology and
private tutors but most of the country
can't
merza lives with his mom and five
brothers and sisters
he's hoping to have a career in finance
but he's worried that cancelling exams
will put him at a disadvantage
i mean i can't imagine any student who
doesn't share
that sort of anxious feeling because you
when when you do exams right you sort of
take things into your own hands
and you sort of just you know use your
own ability to get the results you want
however
this time around it's the teachers who
sort of have the
power in their hands and they sort of
decide your future um
looking back at all the exams you've
done and how you performed in class
um just knowing that sort of knowledge
you know
someone else is sort of governing your
decision whether that's going to
university or whatever
you want to do in the future is it's
quite um
yeah it definitely gives the anxious
feeling in a survey of young people who
work with the social mobility foundation
shared exclusively with safety ridge on
sunday
73 of students said they're anxious
about exams being cancelled
64 said their mental health has been
negatively impacted by school closures
four in ten said they don't have access
to reliable broadband
and 38 said they haven't been contacted
by their school or college
about their technology needs boris
johnson said
that closing schools was a last resort
and it's not hard to understand
why for children who don't have the
right equipment
or frankly the right home environment to
learn in things are really tough
and the uncertainty too is clearly
taking its toll on young people's mental
health
social workers struggling under an
increased caseload are also concerned
i've been qualified as a social worker
since
2005 and i've been working with children
and family
for for nearly well for over 20 years
now
and i've never experienced a time in my
professional
life when services have been under so
much pressure
and so much strain people who have
lost their jobs have been furloughed
people that are on low incomes you know
spending time
at home with each other all of the time
with
really limited resources has seen
a real increase in the complexity
and the harm that some of our young
children have experienced
under the pressure of rising cases and
new variants closing schools was perhaps
inevitable what's important now is a
roadmap to reopening
and a plan to make sure disadvantaged
children aren't another victim
of the pandemic